right to negotiate with whom when and
where it desires to achieve
peace this is not something that should
be dictated by the United States or any
other Nation on this
globe the United States has no right to
tell Israel or any other country what
they can do what they can build on their
territory on their land and when or
where they can build
it it's beautiful that
um representative MTI has signed such
wonderful things uh in P of Israel but
the question is how many of those things
actually pass we know how this political
game is played in Washington where
they'll sign a thing and then they know
it's not going to pass so it's it's you
know it's a meaningless gesture
how many medes like that have we seen
over the years on the whole Israeli
C now let's go a bit further this
Administration has
been you many people say they're just
naive they don't
understand they have
systematically abused our allies not
just Israel but others they throw them
under the bus with it look at what
happened to Poland and the Czech
Republic who were going to mount
anti-missile system to protect against
Iranian
missiles Russia objects Obama throws him
under the
bus we are not shipping weapons and
stuff that the Israelis need it's been a
de facto embargo for the past year why
is that it's not because Congress asked
for it it's because our Administration
is just not doing it
so keep this in
mind when you elect a new Congress in
November it is not
just to change domestic policy here in
the United States it is also to protect
our allies and our friends around this
world because one thing I have
Lear is that you do not throw your
allies under the bus and that is
something they have done consistently I
mean and I just go back to one thing
early IND C was during the
campaign what happened when Russia
invaded Georgia did Obama say a word he
was in aw if I remember correctly the
only people that out there saying was
George W bush and John McCain and they
were the only reason why Russia stopped
from going eating up the whole
country so keep that in mind he gave you
a a open signal about how he treats
allies back in the campaign and he's
just proceeded to do the same strategy
throughout his administration's
power now I think I'm a little short on
the speech part so anyone wants to ask
questions you got an extra one or two
I'll answer those as
well to answer the first part of your
question I'm definitely against the M
down Ground Zero there's
no no reason to build the victory
victory memorial for the folks that
attacked us on
that U too many of us lost friends
family um everything there to an
ideology that is murderous and has
no mercy or compassion for for human
beings and to have that ideology
celebrate his victory by building a a
memorial if you will uh within sight or
the ground zero is an a front to America
um and it's something that I certainly
hope never to see and I am very
disappointed in some politicians like
Mayor Bloomberg who call
us
exk the uh what's your thoughts on that
the treat G discussion is a new start
start two I think it's called or
whatever with the Soviet Union right
it's uh the Obama admin it's the it's
the Kumbaya of nuclear
treaties it's where the United States is
going to reduce this nuclear Aral while
Russia actually has to reduce
nothing I mean and and and comping that
our inspections of our facilities our
nuclear facilities all on um for nothing
can turn we basically threw away a large
part of our DET turn for nothing now the
good part about it is it has been passed
it still has to have Senate approval and
a little Lu it will get to the Senate
before uh before my U my buddy Gary gets
there and I don't think Gary's going to
let it pass it all so hopefully it'll
die a very um quiet death but uh just
the fact that this Administration like I
said they'll throw our allies on the bus
and they'll try to strict the United
States of its power and its deterrence
uh and it's an Administration that has
come through end in 2012 and I hope
all
um there are number of things we need to
do uh first of all we got to strip back
the things they have done already we've
got to reduce the size of government we
got to get rid of the bureaucracies
which have uh grown to the point where
they are passing laws or regulations
without Congressional approval or
oversight that affecting every aspect of
your
life the Zars have got to
go Department of Education which has
never educated a single person in this
United States and only serves to to make
education more difficult increase our
taxes because they have all these
unfunded mandates that the school
systems have to
more report requirement more
Administration that raises your taxes
and doesn't do a darn thing for
Education Bill read the bill p number of
Bill PES of Bill Bills should be a short
number of pages I mean I think I think
Gary has said on the high end 10 pages
and I love that idea CU I don't want to
read 2,000 page bills which is
ridiculous
um
oh he went away right after election
day no he kept
that yeah most transparently socialist
presid thank
you